if alexis navalny has been poisoned by
the kremlin
he wouldn't be the first skripal
litvinenko
magnitsky yushenko all critics of putin
and all victims of mysterious attacks
vladimir karamerza claims to have
survived two attempts
on his own life and is in no doubt what
has happened
to alexei navalny every time this
happens kremlin spokes people
shrug their shoulders and say oh we had
nothing to do with this you know it just
keeps
happening that there are these
astonishing coincidences that these
people who have in one way or another
crossed the path
of vladimir putin's regime keep having
those terrible accidents
some of the most infamous russian
assassination attempts have been in
britain
in 1978 the bulgarian dissident georgie
markov
was poisoned with the tip of an umbrella
whilst waiting for a bus on waterloo
bridge
since then russian opposition living in
the uk
have been the target but nothing as
brazen
and as dangerous as the salisbury
poisonings
it was a turning point our assessment
that russia views some defectors
as legitimate targets for assassinations
the government has concluded that it is
highly likely
that russia was responsible for the act
against sergey
and julia skripal sergey magnitsky
exposed tax fraud amongst high-level
russian officials
but he was arrested imprisoned and died
in jail
11 months later what i learned from this
experience
was the lengths that the russian
government would go
to cover up the murder and make sure
that nobody beared any
responsibility and
what i see happening with the navalny
case
is is almost a mirror image alexey
navalny is now putin's best-known critic
his anti-corruption movement is popular
he has momentum
and he is a real thorn in the kremlin
side
but if he dies regardless of who is to
blame
it could backfire on putin the cost for
putin
if he dies is that the world will
conclude that he did it
and the the consequence of that is that
russia which already has
lots of other problems domestically and
in belarus and elsewhere
has an extra one which they really don't
need
if navalny stays in russia it is
unlikely
we'll ever know for sure what happened
to him but assumptions will be made
of course and however much the kremlin
might protest its innocence
this fits a pattern of behavior
alice the bunker sky news